This is Android Wear.
It's simple, glanceable, and
built around micro-interactions.
Now, the interface is divided
into two primary behaviors.
First, the user can
talk to the wearable.
Okay, Google, set a timer for
five minutes.
You can think of these as actions.
Also, the wearable can talk to the user,
and
you can think of this
as the context stream.
It's sort of like enhanced notifications
that matter to the user right now
because it's the right time or place.
That's the basic framework and
it sets you up for success.
But to really make it all the way there,
you need to carry the design philosophy
into your application as well.
Let's talk about that in more detail.